The feed goes silent and so does the audience...
...after Will Smith takes a swing at Chris Rock...
...on stage at the Oscars.
It all went down after Chris made a crack about Will's wife, Jada Pinkett Smith,...
...and her shaved head.
While Will appears to laugh at first,...
...things immediately turned sour as he takes to the stage,...
...slapping Chris straight across the face.
Uh-oh, Richard!
Oh, wow!
Wow!
The sound on the broadcast suddenly cut out...
...in the moments following the altercation,...
...but international markets saw the feed in full,...
...Will shouting at the top of his lungs,...
..."Keep my wife's name out of your mouth!"
Clearly shaken and unsure how to proceed,...
...Chris responds the best way he knows how: with another joke.
That was the greatest night in the history of television.
Okay.
As for why the joke may have hit a nerve for the couple,...
...Jada was diagnosed with alopecia in 2018,...
...a hair loss condition which she has spoken about publicly many times.